I think legalization will continue to
spread around the country and I think at
a certain point there will be a very
strong liberal backlash because the the
pot market that is emerging he's gonna
get bigger and more professionalized and
it's only a matter of time before the
advocates for legalization realized that
hey we didn't used to like the guy who's
on the cover of Fortune magazine or
Forbes and it's kind of cool now that
that's a marijuana guy actual examples
fortunate Forbes but we weren't really
about big business before and we never
really liked genetically-modified
anything if it was a mango we'd fight it
and that it's all genetically modified
in Colorado it's hard to find what they
call landrace strain of marijuana
something that grew naturally and has
not been modified by man the there's a
second part of legalization that doesn't
yet concern a lot of people but concerns
me and I think will eventually become a
liberal issue and that that is the reach
of the emerging marijuana industry so if
you want to leash this tremendous market
worth billions which i think is true you
create entities organizations who have a
very strong incentive to create as much
marijuana use as possible and not only
that but to create as much problematic
marijuana use as possible if we really
mean to sell marijuana like alcohol then
we mean to create a market where most of
the revenue comes from people who have a
problem that is the business model of
alcohol eighty percent of the revenues
comes from a tiny sliver of the users
it's not the guy who has a drink after
work it's the guy who has six misses his
kids bedtime his marriages and shambles
that's the kind of guy who supports the
industry there's going to be more and
more money in mainstream marijuana in
big marijuana behind
optimizing the experience and delivering
it in a way that just totally bypasses
the the senses like you see in in food
we've become more sensitive and liberals
in particular have become more sensitive
today - what craft food
and what Nestle does and what coca-cola
does to corner us into a set of choices
that involve processed highly profitable
food and that when we try that food it
just electrifies us it just blows us
away the food that these companies are
producing today I mean it is meant to
just overwhelm the senses right they
talk about the Bliss point I think
there's every reason to believe that the
science of processed food delivery will
overlap in the future with the science
of marijuana it's already in edibles and
that's that's troubling I mean that
that's creating a potential monster the
joke in the 1970s when my father was was
big in the marijuana world was well we
don't really want him to legalize it
because if they legalize it it won't be
fun and it won't work anymore there was
some believed connection between the
illegality and the thrill of doing wrong
and sneaking and breaking the the
government's rules that was kind of a
high right it wasn't it wasn't only the
THC it was the idea that we're flicking
off Uncle Sam who doesn't know and when
that's gone well you have to create
something else to make it work and
that's something else is a a lot of THC
and and more use than we currently see
and potentially a problem so it's a
concern